so yes we begin in Pakistan where the
political turmoils surrounding Australia
Imran Khan has taken another turn the
former prime minister addressed the
nation saying police have surrounded his
house in Lahore the 70 year old veteran
politician said that police were
preparing to detain him again Khan was
arrested last week in connection with a
corruption case on Thursday Pakistan's
Supreme Court ruled that arrest was
illegal earlier I spoke to Imran Khan
and began by asking him why he believes
he is the target
what is happening right now clearly is
that the neither the military
establishment which means one man nor
these 12 parties they're too scared for
elections because they're scared I will
win so because of that uh you know
they're doing everything to make sure
that I get out of the race I have a two
assassination attempts on me one was
where I was hit one where I was lucky to
be alive because just you know I got
saved thank God so this is the issue 150
cases on me someone who has not had one
criminal case in last few months has 150
cases including 15 criminal cases in a
day 40 terrorist cases so I mean this is
how to get me out of the race but do you
not feel that by calling your supporters
out to protest you are effectively
inciting violence
look Nick I mean Which democracy does
not allow people to protest peacefully
when they think they've been wronged
name me a democracy
when I am picked up unlawfully I was on
bail they could not pick me up they
grabbed me not just grab me but they
beat up people people got injured they
took me like like an ordinary a
terrorist
what did you think would there not be a
reaction would there not be peaceful
protest on that they were always going
to be protest but what I am saying is
that the Asana was not us and I can
again say that whenever there's
independent investigation it will be
proved that it wasn't us
all right Jesus now from Islamabad with
the latest developments
another day of high political drama in
Pakistan where the leader of Pakistan
Imran Khan the former prime minister has
tweeted out that his arrest is imminent
and police are surrounding his house
this comes after the police gave him a
24-hour deadline to hand over what the
government of the Punjab Province says
are terrorists hiding inside the Zaman
bark residence of Imran Khan in his
speech which was not broadcast by any of
the national networks here in Pakistan
unlike all of his speeches before he
appealed to the police saying that if
you have an arrest warrant come and find
those terrorists and and you should you
should arrest them it is worth noting
that Imran Khan has distanced himself
from all of the violence which took
place in the name of his arrest on May
the 9th saying that this was a planned
conspiracy to bring his politics to an
end in Pakistan and through which
thousands of political workers from
Imran Khan's party and his top tier
leadership have been arrested it is also
worth noting that in the last 24 hours
there are many members of the Pakistan
Tariq and staff who've come out in
public saying that they do not want to
be associated with Imran Khan's party
anymore because they do not condone the
violence which was perpetrated according
to them in the name of the Pakistan
so it has been another extension for
Imran Khan from the courts who've
extended Imran Khan's appearance before
the court from May the 17th to May the
31st where he does not need to appear in
the courts for any cases which have been
registered against him since in the last
few weeks he has also been summoned by
the national accountability Bureau in
the same case which he was charged
earlier that he needs to come and face
questions about why was there corruption
in this al-qadir trust case so a lot of
cases that are being faced by Imran Khan
a lot of people who are leaving his
party that he does enjoy a sizable
support in the Pakistani population and
as the government says that they are no
longer no longer going to be allowing
anyone to take the law in their hands
and Carry Out attacks as we saw on May
the 9th there are rights groups which
are concerned that the government and
the top brush of the military leadership
is talking about holding military trials
instead of trying these people who were
accused of vandalism in civilian courts
well let's bring in Haida ziman Qureshi
who's a member of the central executive
of the Pakistan People's Party joins us
now from Lahore Mr Qureshi welcome to
the program first up why is Imran Khan's
home surrounded
well thank you Nick for having me on the
show uh I've heard the sound bites and
the interview and uh what Osama has just
said uh basically it is not surrounding
uh his uh residence in Lahore the
intelligence agencies and the joint
investigation teams which were
constituted both the uh May 9th uh
violence and perpetrated
pre-planned pre-coordinated uh attack on
Army and public installations for
memorials and national monuments in
Lahore Islamabad the shower uh so how do
you know that can I just jump in there
how do you know that they were
pre-planned and pre-coordinated
because uh all the senior people uh PTI
leaders
um in their interviews in their party
meetings uh while they made a committee
that in case Imran Khan is arrested this
is how uh we will uh fight back Imran
Khan is our red line we will uh fawad
Chaudhary the spokesperson he said then
nobody is going to control these people
and there will be violence that Pakistan
and Nation would have never seen of
scale and magnitude uh Sheikh Rashid and
other leaders of the PTI also uh
spirited spit out Venom and you know
want so uh and and in addition to that
uh if when the police came to serve
warrants a few weeks back in Lahore uh
you have all the footage the
international media also covered uh Army
uh the Rangers the paramilitary forces
police who were unarmed were sown petrol
bombs government vehicles range of
vehicles uh where you know the Bowsers
the firefighting equipment uh they were
attacked police was beaten up the stones
were pelted and armed attack Imran Khan
has been accused there's a background to
that all right there's a background you
said there's a background but his Imran
Khan has been accused of Sheltering
supporters wanted over-alleged attacks
on the Army following his arrest last
week he said to us here on Al Jazeera
that he's offered his house to be looked
at by officials and journalists and he
says he has nothing to hide
well um if he has offered his house let
the investigating agencies go in he
never even allowed a service of Warrant
at his Lahore residence and the last
time when they came there was violence
and the city had to be closed for three
days uh he has attacked twice uh before
the judicial complex Islamabad he has
ransacked the Lahore high court on his
bail hearings he has attacked diplomatic
Enclave after the supreme court judgment
on May the 25th he has
done violence and fueled it in 2014 on
Constitution Avenue uh his people raided
the radio Pakistan the Pakistan
Broadcasting Corporation which is the
equivalent to the British Broadcasting
Corporation so he has a checkered
History of Violence civil liberty uh
movements against the state and then he
has appeased Taliban he's Taliban a Visa
he has contacts with agencies role
who have fought and raised born against
the state of Pakistan but now what he
has done his own party people uh people
in PTI are now jumping the bandwagon and
he is now cornered he is cornered
because before he was
ah you know attacking the military
establishment that why they are not
coming
we're going to run out of time
I do need to get more questions in uh
many of Imran Khan's senior uh members
of his party have been rearrested is
that not a misuse of government power
yes they have been arrested Nick because
they were aiders are better than
conspiracy so anyone who is part of the
conspiracy in every conspiracy home and
abroad you have to haul up these people
there is evidence of their communication
uh there is evidence of their planning
these things and people who have been
arrested the poor PTI uh workers who
were indoctrinated uh who were incited
and propelled and trained for this kind
of violence in case Imran Khan is
arrested have come up themselves on
social media and given their videos that
all the top leaders will Engage The Fat
fee expensive lawyers and the party will
uh you know uh be a spokesperson for
them and uh raise voice against their
arrest while the hundreds of workers who
have been hauled up or who were you know
who whose naiveness probably uh took
them to believe that what Imran Khan is
propagating and this leadership against
the Army I mean what India and our means
of Pakistan couldn't dare do they have
demolished Army installations they have
desecrated uh the the uh
memorials and uh you know people are
really angry across the country
you're also very angry yeah the Pakistan
Army didn't tend to use the Army act in
the official Secrets act to try some of
the protesters that is civilians being
tried in military courts uh it's been
plenty of condemnation as you will know
on that from uh human rights
organizations and the fact is that is no
way to proceed in a democracy is it
well that's a that's a very good
question Nick well uh the the Parliament
and the cabinet and the National
Security committee uh has endorsed but
it doesn't it it has not said that all
cases will be tried under the Army act
or the official secret acts it says and
other laws under the law and the
Constitution which includes uh
anti-terror laws and I I must point out
that in 2016 uh we had Incorporated uh
an amendment all the political parties
after the uh army public school massacre
of 100 plus children uh uh and and
against the Taliban actions uh we had
Incorporated the military courts
amendments which had a sunset Clause so
even the Parliament and the government
had at that State also allowed for a
two-year period to try all these
terrorists under the military course
obviously that's not an ideal situation
and Pakistan people's party has always
had its reservations we feel that people
who have done this they must be taken to
task there should be no leniency there
should be no pardon and the state must
use all its Authority yes but it should
be through a fair transparent trial as
enshrined under article 10A Constitution
finally let me ask you sir let me ask
you finally
ex-servicemen uh they could be perhaps
tried under the official tax or any
public officers
let me finally ask you Mr Qureshi let me
finally ask you what is the resolution
to all of this it's a question I asked
the former prime minister himself
because as Imran Khan himself says you
cannot eliminate a party
that is popular among 70 percent of the
nation even if people leave or they are
pressurized into leaving the party will
remain how are you going to solve this
well we don't need to solve that and uh
he himself is demolishing his own party
where is uh who is the president of PTI
have you ever seen him making any
statement in fact he was the first one
to condemn his own Senior Party leaders
from the core committee have disagreed
where is Assad Castle the former speaker
of the National Assembly where is uh
where are other Senior People the old
guard of the PTI they are not endorsing
what Imran Khan is doing and what he is
doing he is damaging his own water base
it is not the government or anyone who
is shying away Pakistan people's party
has defeated twice Imran Khan in these
by-elections I held in the last six
months one in Multan where uh Imran
Khan's party was defeated and one in
Mali in Karachi so we are not afraid of
elections they can be held tomorrow if
the if the election commission so
decides and if the courts decide we
don't shy away from elections we want to
actually fight him on the political
Arena we don't want to give him the
Escape Route that you know he was not
allowed to contest he was put behind the
bars on the contrary Nawaz Sharif the
former prime minister was behind the
bars before the 2018 elections Pakistan
People's Party leadership was
incarcerated and put behind the bars and
hanged and then was never given a fair
playing field have Pakistan People's
Party been eliminated no okay
we do have to leave it there we do
appreciate your time and your
perspective thank you so much for
enjoying for joining us here in Al
Jazeera hide as a man Qureshi member of
the central executive of Pakistan
people's party thank you